Hello Freak bitches.
That's the good version of it.
Or whatever.
In Dubai in Dubai,
it's interesting because they stopped paying and the fucking workers just start
walking home.
It just all pack their shit and started walking to the edge of town.
That whole place is so crazy that they were ever been there.
So yeah,
there were appalling at such a high level and then it just kind of all came
crashing down.
It's a resource based economy and limited resource based economy and you can't
eventually that's going to go dry no matter if it's now or 50 years from now,
you're banking your whole worth on oil.
These fuckers are going to be hocking rugs like they were in the fifties sooner
than they know it.
And it's going to be a creepy
period for them.
Well,
they also have debtor's prisons,
so you can't be,
you can't be in debt.
You can't just go bankrupt over there.
They just lock you up in jail.
So a lot of people,
they parked their Mercedes at the airport,
got on a flight and just left everything.
But hopefully like,
I don't want to be in jail.
Fuck you and your country.
Take care of exactly what people were living there.
Like Michael Jackson was living there.
Right.
I mean,
it got to be this,
you know,
really the idea of this enchanted paradise place where millionaires and just
sounds like nuts.
And it sounds like the Las Vegas run by southern Baptists.
Yeah.
The whole thing.
It's really fast.
And religious police,
like I got them called on me during my show.
Ooh.
During your show in Dubai.
Yeah.
Oh,
I was,
I was doing a show with Jon Lovitz of all people I guess.
And um,
he,
I was,
I did the first 45,
he did a second 45 and I introduced him in between show.
Now,
you know,
our shows and I come out and this,
uh,
and um,
so I'm up on stage and um,
I had gone up to the top of the Burj Khalifa,
the tower,
the tallest building in the world.
I have now been in four of the tallest structures in the school,
whatever,
blah,
blah.
It's pretty,
it's actually,
you know what it looks like it's the same deal you get in a landing airplane.
You know when you're flying into lax and you're over the what would be Pasadena
and all that Shit and you're that high in the air.
That's what it looks like.
I would just start shitting and pissing him pass out.
But it's all dirt.
It's terrible.
And I even said like,
I think it's great you guys built a tower that high because that's dirt looks
its best from about 3000 feet.
You know what I mean?
Dirt up close sucks,
but all this dirt so great to see it cause there's no,
they implant any fucking trees.
It's all construction.
It looks like shit.
So,
and they don't even like the biggest observation deck doesn't even face the
water,
the Caspian Sea cause they wanted to impress people with what the city looks
like.
So they put the observation deck on the inside.
Well the city hasn't been built yet,
so bullshit.
Anyway,
so I go up to the top of it.
It was originally called the Burj Dubai based on the city,
the Sheikh Khalifa.
The,
the president of the UAE gave them $10 billion to finish the tower,
$10 billion to finish it because it didn't look like it was going to.
And so the on opening day they decided,
you know what?
Fuck this we're gonna name it Burj Khalifa after him,
like this impulse thing.
But you go up in it and I was one of the first 200 people to go up in it,
you know,
and um,
and I go up in the gift shop,
all has shit that says Burj Dubai on it and it's the same bullshit gift shop
crap.
You'd find that the Sears tower or in Disneyland,
it's fucking golf shirts and,
and pocket knives and bottle it
winners.
And they all have burdens.
You buy paper weights where there's water in it and you can shake it all comes
on that little tower.
No.
Sudden
sandstorm,
maybe we right when to get one of them.
It's stupid like,
and,
but it all still said Burj Dubai on it.
I'm like,
this motherfucker gives you $10 billion and you can't replace the bullshit
printed tee shirts in 24 hours.
What you say this?
Yes.
So I basically,
what I said on stage was it's pretty rude to miss your Khalifa.
I think that you,
you know,
that you did this or whatever because I'm not paying for my hotel room.
But when I call room service,
they say,
they say yes,
Mr. Sparks.
They don't say the guy who was in the room before me,
you know,
and I was actually trying to say something deferential,
respectful to the guy.
Right.
You know.
Well it was the fact that I said Miss Sheer Khalifa instead of shake Khalifa
that drove this one guy crazy and he stood up in the back like eight tables back
and people were laughing.
So I didn't see this happen.
He was back in the dark
and he storms out of the fucking place.
Woe is,
I walk offstage to finish my set.
It was great set actually.
It had a great time and there was,
he's like $40,000 tables,
you know,
Evers round tables in the front full of shakes and these guys and if I can,
and women in their hijabs and Burkas and the whole deal.
And then there are business partners with west,
so all,
you know,
it's really weird.
It's like offstage and the promoters there.
And he goes,
uh,
yeah.
Uh,
you said something that offended one of the shakes who was here.
And so he called the CID,
the religious police,
and they're here and they're going to take you into custody.
We'll try to,
yeah,
this is fucked.
That wow.
We'll try and mitigate it as much as we can.
But the fine could be as much as $25,000 and three days in jail.
And,
but we'll try and talk them down.
And it might not be a big deal because we're not even sure what he was upset
about yet.
And we'll try to talk to them about,
but can you go out,
take this out,
can you go out and introduce John?
Fuck,
and then come back and we'll deal with it.
So I walk out on stage and I,
uh,
I go up on date and I introduced John.
And as I'm on there,
as I'm on stage introducing them,
I see them come down the aisle.
I see the religious police,
these,
uh,
four,
there are three of them in these white shirts with the little belts that across
their chest.
And then we'll stick holsters and stuff and they're walking down the aisle
towards backstage and they go backstage.
And I introduced John and instead of going backstage,
I walked straight off the stage and walk right out to the lobby where they had a
table set up for me to sell shit and sign things right.
Whereas where I had intended to go in the first place,
but I walked,
I just,
instead of going backstage,
I went straight out front.
I'm like,
they'll find me out there,
they're going to find me,
they going to find me,
but I'm going to go out there and do that shit first and let them stew.
You gotta sell your merchant.
Yeah.
Right.
So I go outside and I'm taking a bunch of pictures and shit up there totally.
And Dvds and,
and took pictures and blah,
blah.
And I had a bunch of people come out because John is Jewish,
I'm not Jewish.
And they definitely have issues with Jews there.
So a lot of them came,
saw me and didn't stick around village,
the Jew,
right.
Assholes.
Anyway,
so they come out and these guys are back there for 10 fucking minutes before
they realize he's not coming back.
Right.
And so they turn around and come out to the office and right when they walk,
I'm getting a picture with a shake and his wife like this,
like,
like you were in fucking Wisconsin farm around both of them.
Big stupid grin there smiling.
He's got his fucking classic sunglasses,
White Shawl.
The whole deal is white burqa.
You can't even see her fucking,
this is it.
And I'm just a big smiling picture.
I'm assuming she's smiling and um,
and they,
they come out and they go,
well,
if he had said anything offensive,
these people would be,
they would not take a picture with him.
This shaker right here.
And his wife would not be taking pictures if he said anything we're saying
they'd saw it.
There was,
so they basically said,
wow,
he's not,
he didn't offend anybody because if he did,
they would be mad too.
And so they went to the,
the shake.
Who was standing by the doorway.
I didn't know who it was,
but apparently he was standing it and then they walked over with their arms
crossed.
What did he say?
What was the big and he goes,
well it wasn't what he said.
I was just thought that other people might get offended.
He started backtracking on what he said.
Oh.
So they stuck around and watched John Show for about 10 minutes to make sure he
wasn't doing anything untoward.
And I think they ended up finding him $25,000 fine.
John 25,000 mentioning his Judaism too much.
Why?
Yeah,
fuck that.
Don't ever go there.
Yeah Dude Dude.
So cause it wasn't anything else.
I mean he does this thing.
Bob Saget is gay.
This song he does,
which might've been it.
Cause you mentioned homosexuality is worse than mentioning Judaism there.
I think almost they conflate the two.
But it's psychopath.
I mean it's crazy behavior.
Imagine if Fred Phelps,
his family ran Vegas.
Who's Fred Phelps?
The Westboro baptist.
Yeah.
God hates fags at Oregon.
I was like,
imagine if they ran Vegas.
Oh my God.
And every time you were,
you were having a great time in Vegas.
You had to like Kinda stop and make sure that nobody went and told Fred Phelps
his fans.
You have reservations go in there and performing there and do we like that?
It'll be okay.
I not really,
I felt okay about what I was going to say and I knew that like that was an
issue,
but I didn't think I was going through my act going is there anything that
they're gonna come punch.
Did you swear?
Do you swear at all?
Yeah.
Yeah,
the story problem.
No,
they didn't.
They weren't bothered by the sexual stuff.
You're allowed to talk about sex and stuff.
Yeah.
Really?
How much so be level,
I mean,
not by B.
Can you talk about popping pussies and stuff?
I know and I wouldn't,
it wouldn't go there.
What is it?
What is popping?
Posing.
That's what you snap it.
What do you do with your fingers?
No,
you just pop it.
How do you do that?
Just pop it.
What the fuck does,
I don't know.
What that means is songs about it.
You know,
two live crew pop that pussy.
Mm.
I think they just have fun.
Don't,
don't,
don't find that on Youtube.
Whatever you do is you want to fingers moving.
Yeah.
Cut The shit.